what a confusing juxtaposition that
would be my stripper name juxtaposition
is this oh gosh I'm gonna do that I'm
just Christina Ricci's character from
now and then now maybe I'll just do this
I don't take it off at some point huh be
my strippers tagline welcome to shear of
consciousness Monday it's actually
Monday right now and he's 12:41 a.m. and
I just got off a flight back from Boston
mamrie and I did this might get weird
y'all a stage show up there at the
Wilbur theater and it was so great and
my brother was in the show Flula Borg
was in the shell Michael buckaroos in
the shell lohanthony was in the show
hello lohanthony you are adorable and
your mother is beautiful and you have
the tiniest skinniest little legs you're
my new style icon I need one big time
speaking of comedy shows we Hannah and
mamrie and I are doing a nofilter show
in London and Dublin Wow sometime in May
mmm I forget the exact dates so looking
a little a business meeting adjourned
oh hello oh my god I just opened up
tumblr and there are disproportionate
cat photos photos of disproportionate
cats so stupid if this is what it's like
to be in an office ready look at your
computer right now and go
when did my fashion sense become eleven
year old boy I haven't looked at pop
culture for a couple days because we
were writing bits and by writing bits I
mean my bit involved me smashing
potatoes on a stage so you know when you
come to one of our shows expect real
highbrow stuff like you might want to
just wear a hat your eyebrows don't go
up your face why I put on a dress up
like Khaleesi no oh my god Rihanna and
Drake are together I hope their ship
name is rake Amanda Seyfried brought a
knife on a plane oh no the apocalypse is
coming I had to get my tits and butt
patted down by TSA this time it was um
not as invasive as I thought though they
did do this on my butt crack like my
butt was the credit card machine in
their hand was a credit card i proofed a
video of a bulldog puppy and a hoodie
rolling down a hill what yes give it to
my face so if he rolls down the hill oh
my gosh she's in a hooded sweatshirt and
she's a bulldog puppy and she is rolling
down the hill oh my god oh my god she's
flopping herself down the hill that's
how I hope the world sees me just a
bulldog puppy and a sweatshirt flopping
herself down the hill and then putting
it on the Internet do you want me do
want to make me fries oh Jesus didn't
even expect that my fingers were
actually the inspiration fingers for et
padded oh oh ooh subscribe